[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance au sénat entièrement consacré
une fois encore au coville 19 et à ses
conséquences
les sénateurs vont interroger le
gouvernement
pas moins de dix questions au menu et sa
commande en une dizaine de minutes à 15
heures précises
en attendant je suis avec rené paul
savary bonjour je vice président de la
commission des affaires sociales
sénateurs l ère de la marne
un mot tout d'abord et bien sûr le début
de plan dont olivier ferrand a parlé
tout à l'heure à la sortie du conseil
des ministres
et il annonce notamment une hausse du
salaire des soignants même si on n'en
connaît pas encore le montant
bah écoutez c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
doit se faire on en parle depuis
suffisamment longtemps maintenant faut
passer à l'acte et augmenter 'l'indice
de rémunération ne pas jouer comment on
fait sur les primes parce que derrière
il ya des incidences sociales qui sont
quand même importante donc il faut
reconnaître véritablement l'action de ce
personnel soignant alors sur ceux commis
19 on est également en train de faire un
petit peu l'addition est liée à cette
épidémie la sécurité sociale notamment
qui va voir son déficit plongé à 2 40
milliards d'euros et celle de supporter
cette dette qu'ovide pour vous à écouter
ces principes de la sécurité sociale
c'est de faire face aux dépenses
sociales et notamment aux dépenses de
maladie donc dont on n'entend plus et
c'est à elle de porter cela maintenant
il faut que l'état mette les recettes
correspondance pour alimenter le budget
de la sécurité sociale pour qu' ils
soient équilibrés l'état d'ailleurs
selon les échos prépare un projet de loi
qui transfère 136 milliards d'euros de
dette à la cades est la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale
c'est un petit peu technique quel en est
l'objectif
exactement ce que pour vous c'est une
bonne solution écoutez moi je ne je suis
tout à fait dubitatif quant à ce type de
de cavalerie 1
la cadette devait s'éteindre en 2024
pour être la dette sociale qui portait
de 5
milliards d'euros maintenant il ya une
partie de la dette quand encore porté
par l'acoss et environ 40 une bonne
quarantaine de milliards d'euros plus le
déficit cohérent va connaître au niveau
de la sécurité sociale et déjà affichée
à 41 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
mais tout n'a pas été encore entièrement
chiffrée puisque la crise n'est pas
finie
on voit bien qu'on atteint des sommes
considérables
quoi qu'il en coûte aux draps un moment
faire en sorte de payer l'addition parce
que la dette perpétuelle c'est bien sur
le papier mais dans la réalité des faits
il ne faudrait pas qu'il y ait une
hausse des taux d'intérêt parce que nous
serions très mal en contrepartie olivier
verrou dit prévoir également un plan
pour la dépendance qui seraient financés
par une fraction de la csg
là encore est ce que c'est pour vous une
bonne solution cette journée se nourrit
j'ai de faire effectivement un plan
ambitieux pour une manière sans visage
et qu'il était démographique pour la
dépendance
maintenant comme les caves et en sont
les principes
quel en sera le financement je pense que
nous aurons l'occasion d'en délibérer
beaucoup émettre des hypothèses
toujours est il que à un certain moment
faudra le payer 7 aux générations
actuelles de payer pour leurs personnes
âgées ce n'est pas aux générations
ce ne sont pas ce n'est pas aux
générations futures de payer cette dette
est bien merci beaucoup rené paul savary
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je vais
à présent accueillir les sénateurs
communistes de la seine saint denis
fabien gay bonjour bonjour vous allez
tout à l'heure interpellé muriel
pénicaud sur la question des
licenciements
d'ailleurs et bien il ya des
licenciements qui font la une
aujourd'hui renault qui envisage de
fermer trois usines en france de
restructurer celle de flins dans les
yvelines
est ce que c'est pour vous justifier par
le contexte actuel de crise
oui puis on peut citer aussi vos
collègues de bfm et de rmc
c'est injustifiable par exemple renault
c'est 5 milliards de pgr france 7
milliards de pêcheurs nous nous avions
dit que les prêts de les garanties par
l'état
il ya 115 milliards de
mis sur la table de dette directe 300
milliards de prêts garantis par l'état
et donc nous nous avions porté une
condition c'est qu'il y ait des critères
sociaux environnementaux on peut pas
mettre autant d'argent sur la table
activé comme on dit le chômage partiel
et puis maintenant que nous commençons
le décor finement apprendre plans
sociaux sur plans sociaux sinon nous
allons passer du chômage partiel au
chômage de masse et donc ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
il ya une condition d'admettre à ça il
faut interdire les licenciements
tous les licenciements comme en espagne
et préparer en même temps un vaste plan
de relance écologique et sociale sans
nom je dirais c'est des milliers de
salariés qui vont payer la crise et nous
allons avoir une super ami sociale et ça
pour nous c'est inacceptable
oui cette casse sociale est ce que tel
d'empirer pour vous on sait le
gouvernement l'état ne peut pas non plus
se permettre de continuer à payer est
bien tout ce qu'ils payent avec le
chômage partiel mais madame vous savez
que le chômage partiel n'est pas une
chance ou non c'est des cotisations qui
ouvre droit au chômage partiel
alors c'est vrai que nous sommes dans un
moment exceptionnel il ya 12 millions de
salariés qui sont au chômage partiel
mais qu'allons nous dire à partir du 1er
juin est-ce qu'il faut que les gens
après avoir payé la crise sanitaire paix
le drame social non ce n'est pas
acceptable
donc il faut continuer à aider on met
415 milliards pour les entreprises et
pour l'instant l'urgence sociale zéro
vous savez qu'il ya aussi des gens qui
meurent de faim aujourd'hui les files
d'attentes devant les associations
caritatives ne cesse d'enfler et pour
nous ce n'est pas acceptable
il faut mobiliser de l'argent il ya
beaucoup d'argent il ya des encore des
grandes entreprises qui versent des
dividendes aux actionnaires on a parlé
de sanofi on parle de vivendi on en
parle de beaucoup
voyez donc il faut mobiliser cet argent
pour répondre à cette crise sociale et
pour nous ce n'est pas acceptable ni de
casser le code du travail ni que les
gens en paie le prix par le chômage je
vous parlais de ces queue devant les
banques alimentaires notamment
seine-saint-denis où on est la situation
aujourd'hui
il ya eu notamment des propos
aujourd'hui du directeur général du
secours populaire sur le fait que ce
soit très difficile
oui puis mon ami fabien roussel était ce
matin mais le secours populaire en
seine-saint-denis eh oui
le préfet a dit il ya quelques semaines
que nous pourrions avoir des émeutes de
la faim
voilà où nous en sommes rendus et ce
n'est pas que chez nous c'est dans
beaucoup de départements populaire et je
pense aussi à nos concitoyens
ultramarins
donc il faut que l'état aujourd'hui
investissent soutiennent ces
associations un certain nombre de
collectivités aussi qu'ils se rendent
soutien pour que chacun et chacune
puisse se nourrir dignement
je rappelle quand même que nous sommes
la sixième puissance mondiale il est
inacceptable que des gens aujourd'hui
meurent de faim bien merci beaucoup fait
d'avoir répondu je rappelle que vous
aller interpeller tout à l'heure le
gouvernement ait enfin avant cette
séance de questions d'actualité
jacques la sénatrice véronique guillotin
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice rda ceux de
la meurthe et moselle vous êtes médecin
vous avez d'ailleurs repris du service
pendant la crise
un mot d'abord sur cette situation dans
le grand test puisque la rs grand est à
détecter vie nouveaux foyers épidémiques
dans votre région dont un dans la meuse
est ce pour vous source d'inquiétude
comment l'expliquez comment l'expliquer
je ne sais pas puisque je ne sais pas
d'où viennent ces clusters mais source
d'inquiétude mais je pense qu'on est
tous quand même très attentif à ce qui
va se dérouler le déconfinement reste
toutefois absolument nécessaire avec une
vigilance extrême et l'idée est quand
même de trouver ces clusters à leurs
racines de tester
de retrouver les cas contactez un peu de
les tuer dans l'oeuf si je pourrai
exprimer les choses comme ça donc pour
le moment on a quand même une carte
virale une circulation virale dans le
grand est qui s'améliore nettement et ça
c'est quand même source
voilà ce n'est pas seulement la
situation s'améliore quand même
honnêtement oui olivier verront le
ministre de la santé tout à l'heure à la
sortie du conseil des ministres a
commencé à parler de son ségur de la
santé il annonce notamment des hausses
de salaires pour les soignants à sens
tellement plus de détails mais votre
réaction tout de même pas passer
nécessaire je pense que bien évidemment
qu'il va falloir aujourd'hui et ça fait
longtemps qu'on interpelle sur le sujet
c'est pas voilà c'est pas le christ
qu'ovide à exacerber tout ça mais c'est
un sujet sur lequel on est revenu depuis
longtemps moi j'suis sur une zone
frontalière et j'ai alerté maintes fois
là la ministre de la santé de l'époque
en disant que c'était pas possible on
est un pays européen où nos soignants
sont quasiment les moins payés d'europe
et la situation là peut pas perdu en
plein d'idées olivier ferrand notre
système de santé coûte très cher donc
c'est un paradoxe qu'il pointait du
doigt
j'ai pas compris la crise et de nos culs
notre système de santé était le très
cher nos dépenses de santé était très
élevé et en même temps de soignants
étaient mal payés
il faut résoudre le problème il faut
régler le problème des soignants qu'ils
soient payés à leur juste alors juste le
travail c'est absolument nécessaire
aujourd'hui si on veut maintenir parce
qu'un système de santé sans soignant
n'est plus un système de santé est ce
que vous craignez ce qui semble se
profiler qui pour le coup n'est pas du
tout demandée par les syndicats
hospitaliers l'assouplissement des 35
heures à l'hôpital
ça va être négociée avec les partenaires
sociaux est ce que je le crains je sais
pas comment ça va être ça va être
pouvoir être mis en place mais il est ce
que beaucoup de soignants travaille déjà
à 35 heures c'est pas une certitude
voilà les soignants d'être dépasse déjà
pas mal leur faim donc je ne sais pas
comment ça va être je peux pas dire
comment ça va être gérée mais bon je
pense que les gens je pense que les
soignants bosse déjà bien plus que 35
heures aujourd'hui
donc on l'a pas pas vraiment le sujet
que c'est pas forcément pour le moment
la priorité je pense qu'il faut
revaloriser les salaires 1 eh bien merci
beaucoup vernis gotein je bosse je vous
laisse rejoindre la jskt ans qui vient
de commencer à la cloche a sonné tout de
suite on prend la direction de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je réserve usage
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
sur le format adapté que nous avons
définies et qu'avec les questeurs et les
présidents groupe novair reveron dans
les deux semaines qui viennent en
fonction de la situation
notre séance se déroule dans des
conditions de respect des règles
sanitaires mises en place depuis le mois
de mars et nous procédons au nettoyage
et désinfection de l'hémicycle après
chaque séance dans les domaines pour les
micros après chaque intervention
chacun veillera au respect des distances
de sécurité
je rappelle à nos collègues je me répète
mais que les entrées des sorties tiens
c'est vêtue par les portiques et oporto
de l'hémicycle pour le gouvernement
parle devant notre séance et retransmise
en direct sur public sénat sur notre
site internet
je vais donner la parole au président
hervé marseille pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le
président de la république et la
chancelière allemande ont formulé lundi
une proposition ambitieuse qui répond à
l'impérieux besoin de relance économique
de notre continent
elle complète les mesures déjà annoncées
par la commission et la banque centrale
européenne avec les collègues de mon
groupe nous saluons ce projet et nous
nous réjouissons du retour du couple
franco-allemand porteurs d'initiatives
alors que le fossé entre le nord et le
sud de l'europe s'était dangereusement
creuser et que nous avons beaucoup
regretté la réaction tardive de l'europe
au début de la crise encore faut-il que
cette proposition soit approuvé par les
mais la volonté est là des deux côtés du
rhin et c'est déjà beaucoup
pour autant nous allons léguer à nos
enfants une dette d'une ampleur inégalée
cet argent doit être utile à un horizon
qui dépasse de loin celui de la sortie
immédiate de la crise de même l'effort
consenti par les états membres impose
d'utiliser ces fonds dans une
perspective
tif de long terme qui sert les intérêts
de notre continent
monsieur le premier ministre nous savons
aussi que pour convaincre certains de
nos partenaires instruit par des
décennies de mauvaises habitudes et de
facilité il nous faudra leur donner des
assurances solide
ils nous connaissent trop bien dès lors
comment vous pouvez vous garantir que
cet argent sera utilisé pour porter des
investissements stratégiques nécessaires
pour recouvrer notre souveraineté pour
préserver notre environnement et notre
santé
comment pouvez vous garantir que ces
fonds ne serviront pas à alimenter des
dépenses de fonctionnement classique
déjà hypertrophié je vous remercie pour
vous répondre
la parole est qu'au premier ministre
suédois refile il avait la parole
monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs laissez là terme
les sénateurs monsieur le président
marseille vous l'avez dit dans votre
question
une initiative franco-allemande assez
exceptionnel a été annoncée par la
chancelière merkel et le président de la
république il y a quelques jours deux
jours elle fait suite à l'épidémie de
covin à la crise sanitaire que l'europe
a connu à des titres divers et à la
crise économique et sociale qui
s'annonce conséquence directe à la fois
du confinement liées à la crise
sanitaire est à l'arrêt de la production
et de la consommation que nous avons
constaté dans un très grand nombre de
pays d'europe et du monde
je rappelle cette ce chiffre édifiant de
près de la moitié de l'humanité
confiné on se doute bien et on voit bien
les conséquences économiques et sociales
qui vont en découler
est ce que l'europe a été à la hauteur
de la crise beaucoup de nos concitoyens
en france beaucoup de nos amis en
espagne en italie eire diront volontiers
que tel n'a pas été le cas auront-ils
raison de le dire je veux dire est ce
que véritablement les réponses de
l'union européenne
au delà de la perception par nos
concitoyens
est ce que ces réponses auront été à la
hauteur probablement probablement
pourront nous dire avec un peu de recul
que l'union européenne n'a pas rien fait
et qu'elle a été utile dans la crise
mais est ce que véritablement elle a été
à la hauteur de cette crise je ne le
crois pas monsieur le président et comme
toujours lorsque nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation de crise de
difficultés il faut soit le constater
vivre avec
et puis peut-être le cas échéant le
déplorer soit trouver des solutions pour
y remédier bien souvent lorsque la crise
européenne
et là c'est dans la capacité de la
france et de l'allemagne à s'entendre et
à entraîner n'ont pas à décider pour les
autres ce serait inenvisageable
mais à s'entendre pour entraîner que
l'on trouve la solution
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
ou plus exactement ce qui est en train
de se passer puisque la france et
l'allemagne se sont mis d'accord pour un
plan très ambitieux sans précédent
visant à permettre le financement d'une
relance à hauteur de 500 milliards
d'euros grâce à la capacité de la
commission nouvelles capacités de la
commission a créé de la dette de façon à
alimenter le marché
l'investissement la relance ce plan il
repose sur quatre piliers le premier
c'est de dire que l'europe de la santé
ça existe ou plus exactement que cela
devrait exister et qu'il faut donc
investir collectivement
regardez collectivement comme on peut
améliorer les dispositifs de santé de
chaque pays il repose sur la création
d'un instrument qui vise à permettre une
solidarité entre les états européens et
donc entre les européens un fonds de
relance doté je les dis de 500 milliards
d'euros de dette émise par la commission
qui fonctionnerait pour l'essentiel dans
les premières années du prochain cadre
pluriannuel de financement que l'union
discute qui viendraient lui-même en
complément des 500 milliards d'euros de
prêts à gré par l'eurogroupe ce qui
donne des sommes qui sont vertigineuses
est au fond assez peu concevable 1000
milliards d'euros pour financer la
relance et la solidarité auxquelles
s'ajouteront les dispositifs nationaux
en se conjuguant ou en complétant le
dispositif européen 3e troisième pilier
de ce plan la nécessaire accélération de
la transition numérique et écologique et
c'est une réponse à votre question
monsieur le président à marseille
puisque si nous utilisons cet argent
pour renforcer notre système de nos
systèmes de santé pas seulement le
système de santé français
nos systèmes de santé si nous
l'utilisons pour accélérer la transition
numérique et la transition écologique
alors par définition nous préparons
l'avenir et nous renforçons nos
capacités de long terme et notre
capacité à long terme à répondre aux
questionnements de nos concitoyens enfin
quatrième pilier qui là encore va dans
le sens de ce que vous indiquez me
semble-t-il le renforcement de la
souveraineté européenne c'est-à-dire
l'idée selon laquelle cette crise
sanitaire a montré que si nous voulions
maîtriser notre destin il fallait que
dans l'espace européen
un certain nombre de productions soient
localisés qu'un certain nombre de
marchés sensibles soit maîtrisé qu'à un
certain nombre de dispositifs sans
lesquels au fond nous ne pouvons pas
faire face aux difficultés soit assurée
c'est le principe de cette souveraineté
européenne sur lequel la france et
l'allemagne viennent de s'entendre et
c'était le sens des annonces du
président et de la chancelière
il n'y a pas eu de précédent à ce type
de l'annonce pourquoi parce que
et je le dis avec beaucoup 2 2 comment
dire beaucoup de plaisir d'une certaine
façon et beaucoup de satisfaction
l'allemagne a bougé ce qu'elle a accepté
de faire ne correspondait pas à ce qu
elle envisager de faire pendant
longtemps
pourquoi est ce que l'allemagne a bougé
monsieur le président marseillais parce
que la crise est là et parce que chacun
peut la mesurer
sans doute je n'exclus pas mais sans
doute ce point-là sera-t-il sujet de
longues discussions
je n'exclus pas que l'allemagne ait
bougé parce que la france elle-même à
bouger je n'exclus pas que l'allemagne
ait bougé parce que elle a vu que la
france en s'attaquant à des réformes de
structure qui parfois avait été évoqué
mais pas réalisé voulait effectivement
préparer l'avenir sérieusement je
n'exclus tellement pas que c'est la
seule raison que j'identifie pour
pouvoir faire fonctionner de nouveau ce
moteur franco-allemand dont nous savons
tous qu'il est indispensable au
redémarrage de l'europe et d'une
certaine façon non pas simplement à sa
souveraineté mais à son existence
c'est donc une excellente nouvelle qui
ressort de cette annonce conjointe par
le président de la république et la
chancelière une excellente nouvelle pour
nous français pour les allemands aussi
j'en suis certain
et pour les européens dans leur ensemble
et la vie est ainsi faite que ces
excellentes nouvelles qui ne sont pas
encore traduites dans les faits vous
avez raison car il va falloir convaincre
j'ai observé vous aussi sans doute
monsieur le président marseillais que la
bce banque centrale européenne la
commission européenne s'était félicitée
de cette annonce et de cette initiative
c'est un excellent début il va
évidemment falloir parler et convaincre
l'ensemble de nos partenaires
c'est normal mais reconnaissons ensemble
que lorsque la france et l'allemagne
s'accordent lorsqu'en semble l avance en
général elles entraînent
c'est une excellente nouvelle merci
le seul pays dans ma recherche par
l'état notre collègue martin lévriers
pour le groupe de la république en
marche vous la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame murs et les
pénicaud ministre du travail
la crise sanitaire nous a contraints
comme beaucoup d'autres pays à organiser
un confinement de la population
il a paralysé en grande part l'économie
française pendant huit semaines les
trésoreries et l'activité de nombre
d'entreprises ont été mises à mal et
nous ne sommes qu'au début d'une crise
économique dès l'apparition de cette
pandémie
le gouvernement a mis en place des
moyens exceptionnels pour faire face aux
chocs économiques afin d'aider des
entreprises et des salariés à affronter
les difficultés provoquées par le cos
vite dit parle par là que vivent 19
pardon chômage partiel développement du
télétravail fonds de soutien fiches
métiers guide de branche pour garantir
la santé au travail protocole de
déconfinement et cetera
parce qu'il faut faire repartir
l'économie et parce qu'il faut garantir
la santé des salariés
l'état se doit de s'inscrire dans cette
continuité et accentuer la reprise c'est
pourquoi votre ministère confie au
réseau anact aract et au direct un
dispositif d'appui gratuit destiné aux
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
avec un enjeu concilier santé au travail
et performance depuis hier c'était pe
pme peuvent grâce au dispositif objectif
reprise bénéficier de préconisations
gratuite qui propose trois modalités
d'appui sensibilisation conseil et
accompagnement
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
détailler ses modalités d'appui nous
garantir que ce dispositif est simple
d'accès qu'ils proposent des solutions
accessibles à tous en particulier aux
plus petits afin de répondre de manière
optimale à leurs attentes
en cette période de reprise qui génère
de très grandes inquiétudes
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole la ministre du travail
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur martin lévriers
est on certain nous sommes retrouvés
tous dans une situation inédite arrêter
ou ralentir très fortement le moteur de
l'économie pour sauver des vies nous
avons eu raison de le faire
désormais avec le déconfinement nous
savons capable de continuer à sauver des
vies tout en faisant repartir l'activité
économique en protégeant pleinement les
salariés
c'est pour cela vous l'avez citer que
nous avons mis en place le protocole de
déconfinement 64 guide métier élaboré
avec les professions avec les
partenaires sociaux par le ministère du
travail avec le ministère la santé et
qui sécurise les employés les salariés
comme les employeurs j'ai pu d'ailleurs
le constater la semaine dernière sur un
chantier du bâtiment et hier matin
encore à toyota après valenciennes à
onnaing les conditions sont quoi sont
elles respectées
ces guides qui préconise vraiment la
manière de faire les gestes barrière la
distanciation dans tel ou tel métier où
on comprend bien que pour un coiffeur un
chauffeur livreur ou un chantier du
bâtiment c'est l'appréciation de comment
ce geste barrière ce fait doit s'adapter
et puis ça permet aussi de constater que
là où il ya du dialogue social un
dialogue social de qualité ça repart
beaucoup plus vite de façon plus ces
raids
parce que effectivement tous ces gestes
barrières sont discutés dans
l'entreprise donc la question qu'on
s'est posée c'est dans les grandes
entreprises dans les moyennes
entreprises qui ont des comités
socio-économique drh
il faut absolument respecter et essai
guide guide métier et pratiquer le
dialogue social c'est la clé pour la
reprise de l'activité sereine comment
faire dans les petites entreprises qui
ont parfois un représentant des
personnels pas toujours et qui ne sont
pas outillés en rh c'est pour ça que
nous avons lancée hier
ce projet qui s'appelle objectif reprise
qui est immédiatement opérationnel il
est opérationnel depuis hier sur simple
demande en ligne et qui permet aux
millions de petites entreprises qui va
sortir du chômage partiel qui
aujourd'hui est concernée qui va
repartir d'avoir des conseils en ligne
des conseils par téléphone ou un conseil
sur place gratuit a mené par l'anact et
un réseau du ministère donc c'est
opérationnel immédiatement je crois que
c'est très important parce que de
repartir en toute sérénité
au compte- la santé les salariés permet
de repartir sur l'activité dans
l'intérêt économique et social des pays
ce lévriers la parole et de notre
collègue véronique guillotin pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole
monsieur le monsieur le ministre
entre le 6 et le 12 avril plus d'un
million de téléconsultation été réalisés
représentant 28 % de l'ensemble des
consultations médicales contre 0 1%
quelques semaines plus tôt l'épidémie
qu'ovide a sans aucun doute provoqué un
regain d'intérêt pour les solutions de
télémédecine apparu comme un outil
indispensable dans un contexte de
contagiosité dans un contexte de
confinement et d'isolement
mais le succès récent de la télémédecine
s'explique également par la mobilisation
massive et rapide de moyens pour
répondre aux besoins les plus urgents
vous avez ainsi levés pour le
remboursement des téléconsultations
qu'ovide l'obligation de passer par le
médecin traitant et d'avoir eu une
consultation en présentiel dans les 12
mois précédant les avantages de la date
de la télémédecine sont nombreux j'en
citerai rapidement quelques-uns le
renforcement de l'accès aux soins des
engorgement des urgences c'est également
un vecteur d'innovation et de
développement économiques et il permet
par ailleurs une diminution des
déplacements notamment en ile de france
où une étude récente a prouvé que
quasiment 2 millions de trajets
essentiellement automobiles sont liés
chaque jour un motif de sentiers face
aux avancées rapides de ces dernières
semaines
il n'est pas pensable de revenir à la
situation d'avant qu'ovide tant les
attentes sont fortes de la part des
professionnels de santé des élus et des
patients des freins restent encore
élevés je pense notamment au déploiement
du très haut débit dont les zones
blanches coïncide souvent avec les zones
sous dotées
je pense aussi aux nombreux trous dans
la raquette s'agissant de motifs de
remboursement et de la nomenclature des
actes et je pense bien sûr au
financement d innovation grâce à
l'article 51 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2018 car encore
beaucoup trop rigide est beaucoup trop
complexe
les arcs les acteurs de terrain demande
plus d'agilité pour répondre aux besoins
spécifiques des territoires il est
absolument nécessaire d'en réduire les
délais j'aimerais donc savoir monsieur
le ministre
quelle assurance vous pouvez nous
apporter pour qu'en matière dit santé le
pas de géant qui a été franchi pendant
la crise qu vide ne se transforme pas en
piétinement pour vous répondre la parole
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre la solidarité de la santé
résultats que vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice guillotin
vous avez raison avec les sanitaires a
provoqué un véritable boom en du
numérique en santé le nombre de
consultations vous l'avez évoqué est
passé au cours du mois de mars de 10000
à 500000 par semaine 2 1 % à 11 % de
l'ensemble des consultations en 2018
dans ces sujets dont on commençait à
arriver les prévisions pour l'année 2020
était effectivement d'un million de
consultations pour toute l'année
un million c'est le nombre de tombes de
téléconsultation qui ont eu cours la
semaine dernière et il n'y a pas que la
télémédecine il ya aussi le thé les
soins vous l'avez évoqué nous avons
assoupli un certain nombre de
dispositions pendant cette crise
notamment pour que l'hôtel soit soit
rendue plus facile pour les infirmiers
les kinés les orthophonistes les
orthoptistes des ergothérapeutes les
psychomotriciens ou encore les
pharmaciens des avants la la crise le
numérique a été un axe de transformation
majeur pour ce gouvernement depuis le
début du quinquennat vous le savez nous
avons engagé un certain nombre de
chantiers ambitieux autour de la
gouvernance de ce secteur nouveau c'est
un point important de l'espace numérique
en santé pour les usagers avec notamment
le dossier médical partagé le
déploiement d'un bouquet de services
numériques pour les professionnels de
santé qui en est un peu le pendant est
bien sûr le health datable que nous
avons lancée pour tout ce qui a trait à
l'innovation à la recherche en santé
alors nous serons vigilants dans les
semaines et mois à venir pour l'examiner
ce qui pourrait être pérennisée ce qui
devrait être amélioré aussi vous l'avez
évoqué je n'ai pas de doute que toutes
ces réflexions la nourriront les
échanges qui s'ouvre dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé qui a lancé le
ministre de la santé
olivier véran parce que il est vrai
qu'en santé mais dans d'autres secteurs
aussi moi je le vois dans le domaine
social dans le médico social
le numérique a challenge et a remis en
cause nos pratiques le professionnel les
pratiques professionnelles des
professionnels et il faut en tirer les
leçons alors oui la sénatrice dans le
numérique on sentait aussi il y aura un
avant et un après qu'ovide soi disant
convaincu l'homme guillou quelques
secondes
mais rapidement merci je prends acte
en tout cas de la volonté d'aller
d'aller vers une avancée sur la
télémédecine j'aurais peut-être aimé
entendre une petite question sur le
l'ouverture et la position des
remboursements et éventuellement du
réglementaire qui nécessitent encore
d'être ouverte mais je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de débattre
merci la parole était notre collègue
fabien gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et que le juge avait
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
le président macron a prévenu nous
allons souffrir mais force est de
constater que nous ne serons pas tous
égaux devant cette souffrance des plans
de suppressions d'emplois sont déjà
envisagés et tombent comme des couperets
airbus alinéa mpm by la sncf puis france
et la liste n'est malheureusement pas
exhaustive
ce sont ainsi des milliers de salariés
qui vont subir un véritable tsunami
social
comment accepter car français renault
ait bénéficié de milliards de prêts et
envisage aujourd'hui des licenciements
pourquoi avez vous refusé comme nous
l'avons proposé de conditionner ses
aides et ses prêts à des critères
sociaux et environnementaux
en fait votre boussole n'a pas dévié et
vous vous refusez à retenir la leçon du
cic e et autres aides publiques qui
n'ont fait que gonfler les poches des
actionnaires
pire certains groupes opportuniste
profite de la crise pour orchestrer un
chantage odieux auprès de leurs salariés
comme par exemple chez derichebourg soit
les salariés reviennent surtout leurs
conflits sociaux soit c'est un vaste
plan de licenciement de 750 personnes
et que dire de ces groupes dans les
restructurations étaient prévus avant la
pandémie et qui en profite pour les
justifier
comme chez general electric il faut agir
par la loi car sinon après le chômage
partiel
ce sera le chômage de masse surtout que
depuis 2010 est les pans les plans
sociaux peuvent être activés au seul
motif économique qu'il soit passager ou
artificielle plutôt que de casser le
code du travail
nous vous proposons d'interdire les
licenciements comme en espagne et en
même temps de préparer un vaste plan de
relance qui s'appuie sur la
relocalisation de notre industrie la
nationalisation des entreprises
stratégie
et la nécessaire transition écologique
madame la ministre
les jours heureux ne se comportent pas
dans les discours il se met en oeuvre au
prix d'une ambition politique de haut
vol pour être à la hauteur de la crise
que nous traversons
madame la ministre aurez vous le courage
politique d'interdire les licenciements
pour éviter le massacre social pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame la mise
du travail maladie qu il avait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs gay nous partageons un même
objectif mais pas la manière d'y arriver
nous avons le même objectif c'est
l'emploi l'emploi c'est pour cela que
nous avons déployé un système d'activité
partielle de chômage partiel massif
inédit jamais connue en france plus
protecteur d'europe et qui pour les
trois mois actuel protège de 12 millions
de salariés encore 8,6 la dernière
enquête qui sont aujourd'hui au chômage
partiel
la question qui se pose c'est comment
continuer à stimuler à protéger l'emploi
dans la deuxième phase dans lequel nous
sommes montrés qui est celui de la
reprise d'activité économique
progressive les secteurs sont très
inégalement touchés
vous l'avez d'ailleurs souvent entendu
il est clair que l'art et nautiques ou
là vient surtout très touché
l'automobile en partie mais le secteur
de l'agroalimentaire ou la distribution
alimentaire lui a continué grands
heureusement pour les français
pendant tout le confinement son activité
et donc dans ce contexte là ce n'est pas
une démarche générale qui fonctionne
c'est une démarche spécifique adaptée
vous posez la question de l'interdiction
des licenciements toutes les études et
toutes les expériences qui ont été
faites dans le temps en france et dans
d'autres pays on montrait que sur le
moyen terme c'est une machine
entièrement pourquoi parce que ça fait
chuter les recrutements d'une part et
que ça n'évite pas les défaillances
d'entreprises alors oui il ya des
entreprises qui étaient déjà en
difficulté avant c'est sûr que la
situation de confinement ne les a pas
aidés et va plutôt renforcé leurs
difficultés et donc falloir avoir un
examen à la fois sectorielle vous l'avez
dit est donc le premier ministre et
l'ensemble des ministres ont déjà
annoncé un plan sectoriel pour le
tourisme hôtellerie restauration d'un
haut rhin bientôt dans l'automobile et y
aura des plans sectoriels adapté et puis
rossi un plan de relance pour stimuler
l'emploi
l'apprentissage et la formation
il y aura beaucoup de mutations
intersectorielle mais je crois que du
point de vue des entreprises il faut
être rigoureux
le but c'est l'emploi mais il ne peut
pas amener une entreprise à aller vers
la défaillance qui serait encore pire
puisque à ce moment là c'est tous les
emplois qui seraient perdus seront très
attentifs au dialogue social la manière
dont s'est accompagnée et nous serons
très attentifs à la manière dont peut
aussi relancer l'activité par exemple il
ya des relocalisations stratégiques qui
peuvent être utiles dans notre pays
c'est tout un plan d'action qui se
préoccupent la parole et hommes notre
collègue nadine grelet certes sonné pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question à laquelle je
souhaite associer tout particulièrement
le sénateur franck montaugé s'adresse à
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec la
collectivité territoriale
je souhaite tout d'abord saluer ici le
dévouement et le travail des élus locaux
qui ont fait face à ce contexte inédit
de crise épidémique
comme l'ensemble du pays les
collectivités et leurs régies sont aux
prises avec des difficultés financières
sans précédent vous le manque de
recettes ce chiffre dès à présent en
dizaines de milliards d'euros
il est du devoir de l'état de ne pas
abandonner les collectivités pour qui la
baisse des recettes notamment fiscales
risque d'engloutir leur épargne qui ne
représente pas moins de 46 milliards
sans soutien conséquent de la part de
l'état le redémarrage économique que
tout le monde souhaite ici ne pourra se
faire dans de bonnes conditions
vous le savez par la commande publique
les collectivités représentent 70% de
l'investissement public dans les
territoires
ces acteurs locaux sont un maillon
essentiel pour sortir du marasme actuel
or la confiance nécessaire à l'action
publique ne sera pas au rendez vous s'il
constate que pour les 2 à 3 années à
venir leur capacité de financement sont
sérieusement diminué à crédit constant
les collectivités ne pourront pas jouer
leur rôle moteur
alors que des nouvelles équipes
municipales porte de nombreux projets de
développement économique
votre intervention récente
mission des finances au sénat semblait
indiquer que vous étiez consciente de la
situation critique que nous traversons
alors concrètement madame la ministre
quelle garantie immédiate pouvez vous
donner aux élus locaux qui veulent
relancer l'économie de leur territoire
par l'investissement
merci pour vous répondra par l'état la
nomme la mise d'accueillir les
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
la sénatrice pour votre question qui me
permet de rappeler d'abord l'action que
le gouvernement mène déjà en la matière
depuis le début de la crise avec
sébastien lecornu et bien sûr le
ministre du budget gérald darmanin
olivier dussopt que nous avons demandé
au préfet déjà d'accorder aux
collectivités territoriales d avance sur
les douzièmes de dotation globale de
fonctionnement mais aussi de fiscalité
afin de soutenir la trésorerie des
collectivités qui en auraient besoin
je constate qu'à l'heure actuelle pour
votre information et pour l'information
du sénat seule une centaine de
collectivités a eu recours à cette
facilité de caisse ce qui signifie que
au fond globalement la situation reste
soutenable pour la plupart d'entre elles
j'ai également demandé aux préfets de
mobiliser la detr et là des cils avec
souplesse pour relancer les travaux
urgents dans nos territoires en soutien
au tissu économique local
maintenant nous sommes en train
d'évaluer par ailleurs les pertes des
recettes engendrées par cette crise pour
les collectivités vous avez vous même
avancé un chiffre
vous savez que nous avons un travail
d'évaluation que mène actuellement jean
rené cazeneuve président de la
délégation collectivités territoriales
de l'assemblée nationale auquel le
premier ministre a confié une mission
sur le sujet et nous avons bien sûr tous
identifiés des taxes qui ont beaucoup
diminué pour certaines collectivités
comme la taxe de séjour
l'octroi de mer les dm théo la
contribution économique territoriale
évidemment il rendra dans les prochains
jours ses premières conclusions
elles seront étudiées par le
gouvernement dans la perspective d'un
nouveau projet de loi de finances
rectificative
à venir à venir prochainement qui
comportera des mesures en faveur des
collectivités territoriales et puis bien
sûr notre action ne s'arrête pas à ce
niveau de ce budget rectificatif le
projet de loi de finances pour 2021 sera
également un moment essentiel puisque
les pertes de recettes engendrées par la
crise se feront sentir à court moyen et
bien sûr long terme de façon différée si
je puis dire
le débat budgétaire pour le 2021
comprendra également une réflexion sur
l'investissement dans nos territoires
aujourd'hui comme demain comme vous
l'avez dit nous n'abandonnerons n'auront
pas les collectivités locales madame la
sénatrice conclure de nombreux outils
seront existe et d'autres sont mire
seront mises en place madame grès certes
d une réponse en flèche
oui merci effectivement monsieur le
président je vais j'en parle d'autant
plus que je suis très prochainement je
retourne auprès des élus locaux
en tant que futur maire de la flèche dès
la semaine prochaine merci monsieur le
président non ceci pour vous dire
effectivement et j'en témoigne d'autant
plus individuellement que les et les
élus locaux ont été au fond toute cette
période qui sont très inquiets que ces
budgets là ne sont pas effectivement
encore terminée ils font les comptes
administratifs sont en train de faire le
prévisionnel et donc on est loin du
compte mais en tout cas il ya une grosse
grosse grosse inquiétude et ça vous êtes
attendus les élus locaux et les acteurs
économiques qui nous sollicitent déjà
sur le terrain attendent des réponses
très concrètes et rapides
merci madame la sénatrice la parole et à
notre collègue jérôme bignon pour le
groupe les indépendants
le confinement dans le monde du 14 avril
journalistes observent que chaque
juridiction a construit son propre plan
en fonction de ses particularités en
matière de contentieux et d'organisation
c'est le maintien de l'activité pénale
d'urgence et contentieux des libertés
qui prime
la justice civile c'est une autre
affaire d'après cet article aucune
chambre civile ne se réunit pour
délibérer malgré la procédure sans
audience prévue par une ordonnance du 25
mars
longtemps avocat moi même j'ai tenté de
vérifier les informations contenues dans
cet article par un très rapide et
modeste tour de france des juridictions
pour ne pas m'arrêter sur le ou les
tribunaux qui aurait 10 fonctionné
durant une demi journée
j'ai contacté mesdames les bâtonniers
d'amiens et de la meuse verdun et
bar-le-duc monsieur le bâtonnier de
lille béthune et angers le bâtonnier
danger qu'au président de la conférence
des bâtonniers du grand ouest est un de
mes anciens associés du barreau de lyon
pour tenter de bâtir un échantillon
représentatif qui rendrait ma question
peut-être plus pertinent de syrie
j'entretiens avec des bâtonniers engagé
je n'ai pas eu le sentiment d'une
catastrophe généralisée pour deux
d'entre eux tout a même bien marché les
autres se sont exprimés sur l'un ou
l'autre des points suivants petit 1 la
justice avait manqué d'une doctrine
nationale sur ce qu'il convenait de
faire laissant ainsi la porte ouverte à
des initiatives locales mais aussi à des
absences d'initiative de ils ont déploré
que le système informatique utilisé par
les avocats avec les greffes rpva ne
soient pas accessibles par les
magistrats qui travaille à la maison sur
leur portable petit roi la sécurité
sanitaire mettant conflit plusieurs
vérités concurrentes la santé des
personnes magistrats avocats greffiers
mais aussi justiciables de le service
des justiciables en droit de la famille
en particulier
3 la santé économique des cabinets
d'avocats avec le problème entre autres
de l'aide juridictionnelle
quand 4 enfin de dysfonctionnements
nombreux mais pas généralisée liée au
droit de retrait de certains magistrats
rendra impossible l'organisation
d'audience et occasionnant des retards
de jugement il faudrait une mission
d'information une après midi dans kate
ne suffit pas ma question est donc
nourri par des réponses variées plutôt
constructive quelle leçon entendez vous
tirez permettent madame la garde des
sceaux permettant un fonctionnement de
la justice
mieux adapté aux crises la parole est à
madame le garde des sceaux me lisent la
justice sur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs sénateurs mais si
le sénateur bignon merci d'avoir pris
soin de faire cette enquête même si elle
est évidemment il part c'est de
l'honnêteté delà de la question que vous
me posez
il est vrai que le fonctionnement de la
justice pendant la période du
confinement n'a pas été exactement celui
que l'on a pu décrire ici ou là par des
positions très catastrophique la justice
à une partie visible et une partie
cachée la partie visible c'est les
palais de justice et de lieu de
rencontre et évidemment en lien avec le
govic 19 dès le 16 mars nous avons fermé
les palais de justice pour éviter la
propagation du colis nous avons
immédiatement pris plusieurs
instructions pour tous les tribunaux
leur donnant un socle commun pendant
cette période du confinement
mais qu'y at il de commun entre le
tribunal de paris 1800 agents et le
tribunal demande une petite vingtaine
d'agents cela supposait forcément qu'il
y ait une adaptation locale des
instructions que nous pouvions donner au
niveau national dans sa partie plus
invisible si j'ose dire les magistrats
des magistrats et des greffiers ont pu
continuer à travailler
ils ont traité le contentieux d'urgence
les référer les urgences civile les
urgences pénale ils ont rédigé des
jugements je citais les 5650 jugement
civil rédigé à paris les 600 jugement
civil rédigé à lille et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples il y a également
des jld qui ont beaucoup travaillé à
lille également plus de 1000 ordonnance
du jld
bref une activité soutenue et tout cela
a été rendu possible parce que d'une
part nous avons pu dans certains
endroits travail tout à fait
correctement avec les barreaux sur les
procédures nouvelles que nous avions
mises en place je pense aux procédures
sans audience
et nous avons également pu et d'ailleurs
pour les avocats vous le savez le
ministère de la justice au delà des
dispositifs nationale a mis en place un
système à hauteur de 50 millions d'euros
d' avance sur l'aide juridictionnelle à
venir
nous avons pu également bénéficier de
tout le travail qui avait été fait
depuis deux ans mon club j'y pense
monsieur le président tout le travail
qui a été fait depuis deux ans en
matière de numérisation du monde de la
justice avec les réseaux qui ont été
renforcées les ultra portables qui ont
été distribués à tous les magistrats et
à certains greffiers
bref nous devons développer ce travail
sur le numérique
mais il est déjà bien enclenché la
parole et à notre collègue michel raison
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé les soignants n'ont pas attendu
l'épidémie monsieur le ministre pour
démontrer leurs compétences
les français qui ont eu à connaître
l'hôpital avant la crise sanitaire
tenait des gens haute estime le
personnel soignant
car il mesurait déjà le dévouement des
aides soignants infirmiers médecins
brancardier argent nettoyage et depuis
des mois
unanimement ce personnel appelé à l'aide
et dénoncer leurs conditions de travail
ne commettons pas une nouvelle erreur de
diagnostic
le mal est profond le mal est ancien la
réponse ne doit pas être ni contextuel
ni provisoire ce qui serait pire
prescrire médailles et participation à
des défilés guerrier dans le meilleur
des cas une blague de mauvais goût dans
le pire une pique incendiaires le
président de la république a annoncé un
plan pour l'hôpital dont on ignore tout
pour le moment
nous souhaitons tous en connaître les
contours et son articulation avec tous
les acteurs de santé
nous nous méfions des discours de
théâtre ce plan sera t'il penser de
façon locale articulé autour des
territoires des professionnels de santé
qui sont au plus près des malades et des
dysfonctionnements organisationnels
êtes vous prêt à une vraie
décentralisation de la décision et enfin
mettre autre chose que des ars simple
courroie de transmission de l'état
central en d'autres termes
êtes vous prêt à rompre enfin avec le
fléau bureaucratique pour reprendre
l'expression récente des professionnels
de médecine exerçant dans l'hôpital
public
moi je n'aurais poser pour vous répondre
la parole est à avrillé attaqué
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de santé vous avez deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur michel raison
permettez moi tout d'abord de m'associer
à l'hommage que vous avez rendu au
personnel soignant dans cette crise dès
avant cette crise qu'ils soient médecins
hospitaliers infirmiers et oui vous avez
raison il est désormais nécessaire
impératif de mieux prendre soin de ceux
qui nous soigner et c'est en partant de
l'expérience de leurs expériences
notamment pendant cette crise que nous
devons bâtir ce plan pour l'hôpital que
vous avez évoqué chacun devra y être
associée les partenaires sociaux
évidemment comme les collectifs
hospitalier c'est tout le sens de la
démarche que nous lançons que le
ministre olivier ferrand a lancé avec le
ségur de la santé une première réunion
se tiendra vous le savez je pense lundi
prochain et dès la fin du mois de mai
nous organiserons dans les territoires
en partant de l'expérience qu'ont vécu
les les soignants ce retour d'expérience
sur ce qui a fonctionné sur les succès
les réussites les attentes aussi de ceux
qui ont fait tenir l'hôpital pendant
cette crise cette crise a parfois
confirmé des choses que nous savions à
la parfois aussi bousculer nos
certitudes
elle a permis de l'inventivité de la
créativité des nouvelles pratiques c'est
tout ça que nous voulons
oui monsieur le sénateur faire remonter
au des territoires pour bâtir l'hôpital
de demain
alors les français aspirent à une
protection sociale qui soit forte un
modèle de santé qui soit à la hauteur
qui soit efficace et le gouvernement
envie d'aller d'aller vite les
changements ne doivent pas intervenir
dans plusieurs années mais bien d'ici
quelques mois le ministre olivier
ferrand l'a dit en sortie du conseil des
ministres
tout à l'heure nous n'avons nous n'avons
été ni assez vite ni assez fort et c'est
cela dont il s'agit désormais l'objectif
est que ce plan soit présenté cet été
pour traduire tout ce qui peut l'être
dans le prochain budget de la sécurité
sociale et vous aurez l'occasion
si d'en débattre pas besoin de faire un
diagnostic le diagnostic il est connu il
faut désormais aller plus rapidement
il n'y a pas de tabou il n'y aura pas
tabou par exemple dans l'articulation
entre le public et le privé et les
agences régionales de santé que vous
avez évoqué que vous connaissez bien
on sut aussi montré qu'elle pouvait être
en pilotage et en appui et que l'on peut
collectivement avec probablement des
améliorations gouverner en proximité
c'est donc bien la victoire de santé je
conclu monsieur le président c'est bien
à l'échelle des territoires de santé
qu'il faut penser l'organisation des
soins de demain et nous comptons sur les
sénateurs pour y apporter leurs pierres
bien évidemment dans les semaines à
venir
monsieur raison quelques secondes merci
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
répondu sur la partie de la bureaucratie
vous savez qu'on avait un pourcentage
trop important en france de bureaucratie
par rapport aux personnels soignants je
respirais une réponse concrète et je
souhaite aussi sincèrement que non
seulement vous allez faire des espèces
d'états généraux locaux ça a été fait
pour l'agriculture ça n'a rien donné
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il ya une
véritable création de synergie entre
tous les acteurs de la santé qu'ils
soient libéraux qu'ils soient publics
qu'ils soient privés ou infirmiers et ça
vous ne m'avez pas répondu non plus
merci
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente sophie primas pour le groupe
l'est républicain vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le voilà monsieur le premier
ministre je vous pose cette question
comme yvelinoise les yvelines premier
département automobile d'île de france
et j'y associe l'ensemble de mes
collègues chinois monsieur le premier
ministre personne n'ignore ici les
difficultés du groupe renault une
gouvernance et un management de
difficile bouleversé résultats
difficiles commerciaux industriels des
tensions avec nissan personne n'ignore
cela se rajoute bien sûr aujourd'hui les
effets de la crise renault vient
d'annoncer -79% de vente en avril en
europe hier soir des informations ont
été publiées par la presse indiquant que
le plan de restructuration attendue du
groupe renault se traduirait par la
fermeture ou la transformation au cours
au moyen terme de plusieurs sites dont
principalement le site de flins sur
seine
monsieur le premier ministre l'état est
un actionnaire important du groupe
renault il ne méconnaît donc en rien ses
intentions le plan de soutien de relance
du secteur automobile annoncé par bruno
le maire serait fondée sur un modèle je
cite plus durable le site de flins sur
seine qui s'appuie sur un écosystème
puissant de sous traitants locaux sur la
proximité de centres de recherche sur le
véhicule autonome et propres ailes le
site de production emblématique de zoé
au coeur d'un territoire d'industrie que
vous avez mis en place récemment
il est donc le site idéal pour servir de
point de départ à cette stratégie de
transformation vers plus de durabilité
il ne saurait monsieur le premier
ministre en être autrement
et d'ailleurs vous allez probablement
octroyés dans les jours qui viennent un
prêt garanti de l'état de 5 milliards
d'euros à renault en souhaitant
conforter sa tranchée électrique
monsieur le premier ministre pour y est
vous nous confirmer que l'état
n'acceptera pas de renault un plan de
restructuration synonyme de
désindustrialisation
mais appuiera et investira pour un plan
de transformation assurant un véritable
avenir industriel de long terme sur le
coeur de métier de renault la
construction automobile
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
c'est quelque chose renault 7
un fleuron de notre histoire
industrielle de notre histoire
économique de notre histoire sociale
aussi à bien des égards c'est un groupe
mondial par l'alliance qu'il a su
construire et défendre avec nissan et
avec mitsubishi
c'est un groupe enraciné dans notre pays
vous avez cité flins dans les yvelines
bien entendu je pourrais moi même site
et sandouville dans cette maritime dont
je me réjouis d'ailleurs que et puisse à
nouveau fonctionner le 22 mai prochain
et c'est un groupe dont l'état est
actionnaire
nous sommes donc attentifs extrêmement
attentifs vous l'imaginez bien il ya
deux choses qui sont mal qui sont à
constater avec la force de l'évidence
d'abord le secteur automobile pas
seulement en france
partout dans le monde connaît un coup de
frein si vous me permettez cette
expression massif et brutale vous avez
cité les chiffres des diminutions de
ventes pour le mois d'avril de l'ordre
de 75 à 80 % du jamais vu et ce chiffre
tout laisse à penser qu'il ne devrait
pas être excellent non plus au mois de
mai et il c'est vrai pour renault comme
ça l'est d'ailleurs pour tous les autres
constructeurs à des degrés parfois un
peu divergent néanmoins dans des ordres
de grandeur qui sont assez similaires
donc premiers éléments le secteur
automobile dans sa globalité connaît une
transformation
massive ait jamais vues dans une
brutalité une intensité jamais deuxième
élément que personne ne conteste et qui
était d'ailleurs déjà dans l'atmosphère
si j'ose dire avant la crise que nous
connaissons la nécessité pour renault
comme pour d'ailleurs toutes les acteurs
industriels singulièrement les acteurs
automobiles de poursuivre d'accélérer et
d'approfondir ces opérations de
transformation et d'adaptation parce que
le marché compétitif parce que la
compétition d'ailleurs sur le secteur
automobile est féroce parce que les
transformations de produits sont doivent
être rapides avec l'électrification avec
la diminution des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre avec la nécessité donc
d'adapter cette culture automobile aux
exigences des temps nouveaux si vous
permettez ces grands mots enfin c'est
quand même bien ça dont il s'agit
la stratégie la nécessité que renault
dans laquelle renault se trouve c'est
d'abord d'abord de renforcer l'alliance
vous savez que pour renault c'est un
objet un enjeu vital
c'est ensuite d'adapter ses modèles son
organisation aux circonstances que nous
connaissons
c'est de renforcer sa compétitivité et
c'est un effort qui doit toujours être
assumés consentis car on ne vit pas
durablement dans le marché automobile si
on n'est pas compétitive et et on
disparaît rapidement sécurisé sa
capacité d'investissement
les coûts fixes de renault sont
considérables
comme toute grande entreprise
industrielle d'ailleurs sans recettes
parce que sans vente
la sécurisation de ses capacités de sa
trésorerie et de ses capacités
d'investissement bien l'enjeu majeur est
l'état vous l'avez dit est au rendez
vous pour la compagnie je pense que le
constructeur du parent directeur de la
stratégie de cette entreprise j'ai pas
son président mais je pense que le
constructeur doit formuler un plan qui
est un plan non pas défensif mais
offensif il est toujours mieux dans ces
circonstances de franchir plus vite
encore les étapes qu'on prévoyait de
franchir plutôt que d'essayer de
défendre le plus longtemps possible une
position qui en vérité serait un table
nous serons extrêmement attachés
intransigeant même je dirais à la
préservation du site france décident
france renault est une entreprise
mondiale c'est vrai mais enfin ça marque
française est évidente et donc nous
serons extrêmement exigeant sur ce point
nous serons extrêmement exigeants sur le
fait que la france demeure le centre
mondial pour renault de l'ingénierie de
la recherche de l'innovation du
développement
c'est quelque chose dont vous savez
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines
c'est combien ces précieux pour préparer
l'avenir et pour garder une capacité à
préparer l'avenir nous serons
extrêmement attaché et je crois que le
président de l'entreprise est
extrêmement attaché lui aussi à la
qualité du dialogue et de
l'accompagnement social
personne ici ne met en doute je crois
les capacités et l'attachement du
président de renault à au dialogue et à
l'accompagnement social dans les
décisions et dans la stratégie qui doit
être prise c'est avec cette ce prisme
que nous allons étudier les propositions
du constructeur
vous avez évoqué des informations
relatives à un plan qui n'a pas encore
été présenté il est donc difficile
vous comprendrez parfaitement je pense
quand même la sénatrice pour moi de
répondre dans le détail un plan qui
n'est pas encore présente et qui n'est
donc probablement pas encore arrêté mais
je veux dire et rappeler et répondre à
votre question en disant notre
attachement au site de flins qui en
effet représente quelque chose dans le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise et qui
doit dans toute la mesure du possible
être préservé parce qu'il est je les dis
important
parce que nous sommes attachés aussi de
france et parce que il y a une forme de
responsabilité de l'entreprise a avancé
à se transformer à expliquer le besoin
de transformation mais aussi à tenir
compte des réalités du pays qui
l'accueille et qui d'une certaine façon
la fait vivre
madame la présidente quelques secondes
quelques secondes merci monsieur le
président pour dire au premier ministre
que depuis très longtemps tous les élus
territoriaux et j'ai eu
valérie pécresse ce matin présidente de
la région le président du département
tous les élus territoriaux on est
volontaire depuis de nombreuses années
pour accompagner la dynamique de
transformation de l'industrie automobile
d'une façon générale d'ailleurs dans le
département des yvelines
nous supportons plus la
désindustrialisation continue de notre
territoire et pour cela nous sommes
prêts à investir auprès de l'état et
auprès de renault pour assurer cette
transformation de notre département
merci la parole de notre collègue
bernard jomier pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le 26 février dernier j'ai
interrogé olivier ferrand dans cet
hémicycle sur les moyens attribués aux
hôpitaux aux professionnels de ville
pour faire face à l'épidémie de kobe
dans sa réponse courtoise comme toujours
aujourd'hui j'aimerais que la volt soit
précise avec mes collègues jacques bigot
et olivier jacquin je souhaite vous
interroger d'abord sur l'hôpital ou de
rythme de décisions s'imposent
un rapide ne sait nécessitant
effectivement pas des mois et des mois
des changes qui est la revalorisation
des rémunérations n'en restait pas aux
mesures parcellaires et homéopathique de
votre prédécesseur
la réponse doit nous conduire à
rétribuer nos personnels soignants comme
un pays européen qui place la santé
publique
au premier rang de ses priorités quand
annoncerez vous des décisions en la
matière un second tempo impose de
repenser l'organisation de notre système
de soins de revoir la place les missions
et l'organisation de l'hôpital et en
particulier de redéfinir ses moyens en
fonction de ses missions et non l
inverse
le président de la république a à demi
mots semblaient admettre les carences de
la loi de 2010 neuf qui n'a pas su
défaire les méfaits du concept d'hôpital
entreprises c'est un premier pas il faut
aussi redéfinir l'articulation avec les
acteurs de vie les mails médico sociaux
écarté pendant de près de deux mois de
la gestion de l'épidémie par une
décision prise au sommet alors qu'ils
ont bien souvent démontré leur capacité
d'adaptation et de réponse au plus près
du terrain leur capacité à aller vers
les populations et les territoires les
plus touchés par l'épidémie suez qui est
le fondement de toute réponse efficace
sur ces chantiers un nouveau catalogue
de mesures un nouveau projet de loi
parachute et d'en haut avec des experts
serait une nouvelle erreur et les
indications d'olivier véran il y à
quelques heures ne nous rassure pas à ce
sujet il faut maintenant des états
généraux impliquant l'ensemble des
acteurs et les français bien sûr
comment concevez-vous ce temps quelles
garanties pour assurer que les usages et
les soignants d'hôpital ou deux villes
seront écoutés entendus et quel en est
le calendrier je vous remercie pour vos
réponses la parole est aux secrétaires
d'état donc près des ministres de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur joe mais je vais m'évertuer
être aussi courtois que que précis je
sais d'une part que vous suivez avec
attention ce tous ces sujets là depuis
longtemps je sais aussi que vous avez
passé plusieurs semaines pendant la
crise à l'hôpital de melun et je ne
doute pas que vous aurez des
propositions très concrètes née de cette
expérience a formulées durant les
semaines à venir sur ce qui va et ce qui
ne va pas depuis plusieurs années car
nous le savons vous le savez chacun sur
ses bancs le sait le mal être des
soignants ne date pas de 2010 est bien
évidemment alors cette réforme à
laquelle nous engageons est beaucoup
plus vaste que uniquement l'hôpital vous
l'avais un peu évoqué puisqu'elle va
couvrir l'ensemble du champ de la santé
en impliquant le médico social mais
aussi la médecine de ville évidemment et
nous l'avons pensé engagé depuis notre
arrivée pour mettre fin à des années de
dégradation et de sous-investissement
alors aujourd'hui la feuille de route et
est clair nous allons augmenter les
rémunérations des personnels soignants
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises par le
président la république par le premier
ministre par le ministre de la santé
nous allons proposer un plan
d'investissements ambitieux vous savez
qu il était déjà question d'une reprise
importante de la dette des hôpitaux mais
d'autres voix peuvent être explorées en
complément et nous allons enclencher une
transformation profonde de tout ce qui
ne tirent pas ne tire pas pardon
l'hôpital et la santé de nos concitoyens
vers le haut et il y a une seule
contrainte
monsieur le sénateur la seule contrainte
c'est d'être à la hauteur des attentes
des soignants et d'engager très
concrètement des transformations wii qui
seront profondes durable les moyens
seront au rendez vous et nous allons
travailler avancer ensemble avec les
soignants avec les passions je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure sur la méthode
le ministre olivier ferrand a annoncé la
mise en place aussi d'une plateforme
numérique ou les soignants vont pouvoir
venir alimenter de leurs propositions de
leur expérience pour créer ce modèle
territorial de santé ensemble ou qui
sera de ces non seulement l'hôpital mais
aussi qui associera la médecine de ville
et le médico social
olivier ferrand vous le savez écoute
depuis son arrivée l'ensemble des
acteurs et il c'est avec eux avec vous
aussi qu'il veut construire la santé de
demain c'est tout le sens conclut lionel
qui débutera lundi prochain
la parole est à d'autres collègues
catherine fournier pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
c'est une question partagée est porté
par mon collègue jean marie
vanlerenberghe que je vais vous poser
le 7 mai dernier monsieur le premier
ministre annonçait le versement d'une
prime pour le personnel des ehpad via
l'assurance maladie ce dont nous nous
réjouissons tous bien sûr mais pas un
mot pour le personnel intervenant au
domicile des personnes dépendantes
rien pour ces salariés engagés en
première ligne depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire et qui ont permis aux
plus fragiles âgées ou handicapées
d'être pris en charge et de mieux
supporter l'isolément liés au
confinement
c'était pourtant la promesses qui
avaient été faites par le premier
ministre lui-même le 15 avril dernier
dans un communiqué publié le 11 mai
monsieur le ministre de la santé a
cependant réaffirmé sa volonté
d'accorder une prime en phase ii en
faveur de cette profession tout en
souhaitant que celle-ci soit financée
est versée au sade essyad par les
conseils départementaux dont c'est la
compétence
or vous le savez bien ce mécanisme de
caen ne garantit pas une égalité de
traitement des aides à domicile sur tout
le territoire puisque le financement de
cette prime dépendra de l'état
budgétaire de chaque département
il serait donc injuste que ces salariés
pâtissent de la gouvernance dont ils
dépendent
la crise sanitaire a démontré leur
dévouement leur écoute
ils forment un maillon essentiel dans la
chaîne des soins par leur mobilisation
ils ont contribué ce que l'hôpital ne
soit pas submergés ils étaient présents
travailleurs de l'ombre d'aucun dirait
invisible de la république
la réalité est là il souffre d'une
rémunération basse de l'ordre de 900
euros net par mois
rémunération qui n'est pas en adéquation
avec l'effort fourni monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple allez
vous attribue à cette profession dans
des conditions de justice et d'égalité
territoriales une prime financé par
l'état et qui va l'en à celle que vous
comptez versées aux personnels des ehpad
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et fall secrétaire d'état freddy
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice cette crise n'at elle n'a pas
révélé elle a probablement davantage
exacerbé la vulnérabilité d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens des personnes
âgées qui sont à leur domicile les
personnes qui sont moins autonome que
chacun d'entre nous et face à cela
oui il ya un rôle primordial qui a été
mené au quotidien qui s'est trouvée
renforcée pour toutes les personnes qui
interviennent ces aides à domicile et il
est effectivement important il est
indispensable il est juste même vous
avez utilisé ce mot de reconnaître le
travail et les missions accomplies par
les aides à domicile pendant cette
période
beaucoup de professionnels s'interrogent
vous en faite le relais aujourd'hui et a
raison sur les conditions de versement
d'une prime exceptionnelle et services d
aide à domicile relève vous le savez
vous l'avez évoqué de la compétence des
départements et vous le savez aussi
c'est une situation différente pour les
ehpad où les ciadoux c'est l'assurance
maladie qui financera la totalité des
primes partout les talent pouvait il est
intervenu les infirmières qui exercent
dans les services de soins infirmiers à
domicile intégralement rémunéré par
l'assurance maladie la prime leur a été
accordée pour les personnels des ehpad
qui sont des établissements que
l'assurance maladie aux finances en
partie la prime a été accordé en
revanche les services d' aide à domicile
relève de la compétence de
départementale alors l'état travaillent
depuis plusieurs semaines
kaminis jacqueline gourault olivier
verront sur ce sujet là en concertation
avec tous les départements et je
réaffirme ici le souhait du gouvernement
effectivement qu'un geste soit fait en
faveur des aides à domicile cela a été
dit à l'association des départements de
france si vous me permettez de changer
de casquette un instant pour revêtir
celle de la protection de l'enfance
j'ai dit la même chose pour les
travailleurs sociaux à l'association des
départements de france
enfin dans le cas du ségur de la santé
il y aura une réflexion vous l'avez
compris sur le secteur médico social où
il faudra que nous terminions enfin avec
ses silos entre la médecine de ville
l'hôpital le médicaux le médical le
médico-social le social
et que nous puissions à l'avenir avoir
des réponses plus uniforme merci mes
chers collègues nous en avons terminé
mais par courrier en date du 19 et
monsieur le premier ministre m'a informé
que le gouvernement fera en application
de l'article 50-1 de la constitution une
déclaration suivie d'un débat et d'un
vote relatives aux innovations
numériques dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie de covin 19 et ce le mercredi
27 mai au soir
en conséquence la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi relatifs à diverses
dispositions liées à la crise sanitaire
à d'autres mesures urgentes
ainsi qu'au retrait du royaume uni de
l'union européenne est reportée au jeudi
28 mai à l'issue de l'ordre du jour
réservé au groupe socialiste et
républicain et éventuellement sera
poursuivie le soir acte est donné après
concertation avec les présidents de
groupes nos gouvernements nous pourrions
prévoir à la suite de la déclaration du
gouvernement étant attribué aux groupes
politiques répartis de la manière
suivante 7 minutes pour les groupes les
républicains socialistes et républicains
union centriste
cinq minutes pour les autres groupes et
trois minutes pour les sénateur
n'appartenant à aucun groupe
après la réponse du gouvernement
s'ouvrir à une séquence de 11 questions
réponses à raison de trois questions
pour le groupe l'est républicain deux
questions pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain et le groupe de l'union
centriste est une question pour les
autres groupes
il n'ya pas d'observation il en est
ainsi décidé chers collègues je vais
lever la séance je rappelle que notre
prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
le 27 mai 2000 20 à 15 heures mais que
le mardi 26 mai à 9h30
nous les reprenons se déroulera une
séance de questions orales
l'un séance est levée
je
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui se
termine donc sur cet agenda est sûre
cette déclaration pour la semaine
prochaine on a donc appris que le débat
la déclaration du gouvernement suivie du
débat sur ce top cow vide aurait lieu au
sénat mercredi 27 mai au soir
cette séance de questions d'actualité à
cenon ont été largement consacré une
nouvelle fois au qu'ovide 19 et aux
conséquences de cette épidémie
conséquence décliné sur le volet social
le volet économique au niveau bien sûr
du ségur de la santé ce nouveau plan
pour l'hôpital qui n'a pas encore été
détaillé
mais aussi autour de la dimension
européenne de cette crise
l'union européenne n'a pas rien fait a
d'ailleurs expliqué le premier ministre
edouard philippe
mais pour lui et bien cette union
européenne n'a pas toujours été à la
hauteur écouter le premier ministre est
ce que véritablement elle a été à la
hauteur de cette crise je ne le crois
pas monsieur le président et comme
toujours lorsque nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation de crise de
difficultés il faut soit le constater
vivre avec
et puis peut-être le cas échéant le
déplorer soit trouver des solutions pour
y remédier bien souvent lorsque la crise
européenne
et là c'est dans la capacité de la
france de l'allemagne à s'entendre et à
entraîner n'ont pas à décider pour les
autres ce serait inenvisageable
mais à s'entendre pour entraîner que
l'on trouve la solution
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
ou plus exactement ce qui est en train
de se passer puisque la france et
l'allemagne se sont mis d'accord pour un
plan très ambitieux sans précédent
visant à permettre le financement d'une
relance à hauteur de 500 milliards
d'euros grâce à la capacité de la
commission nouvelles capacités de la
commission a
créer de la dette de façon à alimenter
le marché
l'investissement la relance voilà pour
cette réponse d'eads à philippe qui a
ouvert le bal de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement une réponse
qui était consacrée à l'union européenne
et au plan franco-allemand de 500
milliards d'euros
à noter qu'il n'y a pas eu de questions
sur les élections municipales lors de
ces questions d'actualité elle devait
pourtant bien être dans les esprits à
mes côté la présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques la sénatrice et
laird et évelyne sophie primas bonjour
vous avez posé une question et bien sûr
ce plan de restructuration au tour de
renault avec notamment restructuration
pour flins dans les yvelines
avez vous été satisfait par la réponse
d'edouard philippe edouard philippe qui
a dit qu'il était très attaché à la
préservation des sites france mais qui
n'a pas commenté plus que cela ce plan
qui dit ne pas encore connaître
je crois que c'était très important pour
moi de poser cette question pour alerter
le gouvernement sur des bruits qui sont
des bruits persistants le premier
ministre a bien noté que le plan de
restructuration n'est pas encore publié
par le groupe renault donc
officiellement rien aujourd'hui n'est
décidé rien ne commence à être négociées
néanmoins la deuxième fois ce qui
concerne le site de flins que nous avons
des bruits relayées par la presse sur un
avenir en tout cas interrogé sur ce site
de flins sur seine
et donc voilà c'est mon territoire c'est
c'est ma ville c'est mon territoire
d'une heure yvelines et c'est très
important pour le département des
yvelines et vous êtes par ailleurs
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques or l'état et premier
actionnaire de renault avec 15% du
capital il prévoit de garantir un prêt
de 5 milliards d'euros pour le
constructeur cela a été rappelé à
plusieurs reprises lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est un problème pour vous oui c'était
c'est pas un problème en tout cas ça
doit donner des grandes orientations sur
les sites et sur la stratégie que
renault va devoir suivre on sait que
l'électrification de son parc de
véhicules est important c'est la raison
pour laquelle je ne comprendrais pas que
le site de renault flins subissent des
transformations extrêmement importante
et structurel puisque c'est le site
emblématique de la non moins
emblématique zoé qui le risque qu'a pris
carlos ghosn ya quelques années en
orientant la production de renault sur
cette voiture électrique qui aujourd'hui
la première voiture en part de marché
donc il y aurait quelque chose de
paradoxal et de contradictoire entre la
volonté de relocalisation industrielle
du gouvernement sa volonté de
verdissement dans le soutien à
l'industrie automobile
nous sommes là au coeur de la
problématique est ce que vous jugez
qu'il faut finalement assujettir les
aides de l'état à des exigences sociales
l'état qui a déjà imposé de ne pas
verser de dividende à ce qu'il faudrait
aller plus loin sur ces plans de
restructurer je ne suis pas sûr que
d'imposer des choses dans le cadre de la
restructuration industrielle c'est tout
le temps pertinents en tout cas il faut
au moins être sûr que ça soit pas
contradictoire avec ses objectifs
l'objectif du gouvernement ces
relocalisations réindustrialisation
transition écologique
là où entre l'avenir du site de flins
qui réunit toutes les conditions et les
ambitions du gouvernement je vois pas
une feuille de papier donc je verrai une
grosse seconde grosse contradiction dans
toute autre décision
eh bien merci beaucoup sophie primas
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je vais
à présent avoir le plaisir d'accueillir
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
jacqueline gourault bonjour bonjour
c'est un sujet dont
n'a étonnamment pas parlé lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement mais qui est certainement
dans les esprits de beaucoup de
sénateurs
je parlais des municipales les chefs de
partis sont conviés à matignon
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure pour parler du
second tour des municipales
vous entendez déjà l'opposition qui
accuse le gouvernement de vouloir ouvrir
le parapluie de vouloir partager les
responsabilités
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez est ce
le cas je leur réponds que quand on est
un acteur de la vie publique française
de la vie politique française c'est bien
normal que les différents les
différentes institutions les groupes
politiques les chefs de partis donnent
leur avis
ça me semble de la transparence
démocratique après chacun sait que la
responsabilité de prendre le décret
adviendra ce sera le gouvernement mais
le gouvernement aura partagé les avis
avec les forces politiques de notre pays
pour vous at-il encore souhaitable
d'organiser un débat et un vote au
parlement sur la question du second tour
on a senti en début de semaine que
c'était plus incertain c'est le premier
ministre qui en décidera cette journée
aujourd'hui est importante puisqu'il
voit l'ensemble des partis politiques
avec leur chef de parti
donc je pense que le le premier ministre
prendra sa décision à la suite de cette
consultation
alors on entend un déjà certains se
positionner par exemple le président du
groupe la république en marche au sénat
françois patriat mais aussi par exemple
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale
ils ne sont pas très favorables à des
élections municipales en juin
il préférait même mars 2021 est ce que
vous êtes de leur avis chacun exprime
son avis bon et ses préférences
ce que je sais moi c'est qui hier par
exemple le président de la république
avait organisé une réunion avec 21
maires de france la même réunion qu'il y
a quelques semaines
et nous avons évoqué ce sujet et les 21
mère qui était la représentante août
strates toutes tendances politiques et
cetera ont exprimé tous la volonté que
ça se passe en juin donc être considéré
pouvoir aussi lancé c'est pratique c'est
un constat que je fais et bien sûr le
président de la république et le premier
ministre prendront leur décision après
avoir écouté l'ensemble des forces
politiques
comment faire campagne pour vous c'est
finalement les difficultés soulevées par
le conseil scientifique elle était moins
sur la date que sur les difficultés à
faire campagne et finalement ne sait pas
quand est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver des
réelles bonnes conditions pour pouvoir
faire oui alors c'est vrai que c'est ce
que dit le conseil scientifique il parle
moins de la journée du vote où les
gestes barrières les installations vont
sécuriser le vote que la campagne en
elle-même
alors ceci dit il faut toujours
relativiser peut-être je le dis comme
cela vous savez qu'en temps normal si un
deuxième tour avait lieu dans un timing
si je puis dire classique c'est un
deuxième tour qui se fait en une semaine
puisque s'il n'y avait pas eu report du
deuxième tour vous avez des délices qui
sont déposés le mardi soir et vous avez
jusqu'au vendredi soir pour faire
campagne c'est à dire c'est à dire que
vous avez trois jours pour faire
campagne
bon là il faut aussi imaginer que une
campagne puisse se faire un peu
différemment ou puisse utiliser aussi
les visions conférence était terrassé ce
que nous n'arrêtons pas de faire au
gouvernement depuis le confinement même
encore maintenant puisque nous avons
aidé confinement progressif donc on peut
être aussi créatif
est arrivé sûrement encore à faire
campagne de cette manière eh bien merci
beaucoup jacqueline merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et vous étiez
bien présente là ici dans cette salle
merci beaucoup
maintenant à mes côtés les présidents du
groupe l air au sénat bruno retailleau
bonjour bonjour sur ce sujet des
municipales étaient certainement dans
toutes les têtes même s'il n'ya pas eu
de questions tout à l'heure vous êtes
vous favorable à des municipales le 28
juin depuis le départ j'ai indiqué que
les municipales ça devait pas être un
choix politique
ça devait simplement être un choix
sanitaires pour la santé des français
ou bien c'est possible et en os x est
vraiment possible pour l'instant le
comité scientifique est extrêmement
prudent si c'est possible
vraiment avec le deuxième rapport il ne
dit pas que c'est impossible non il dit
qu'il va y avoir un deuxième rapport
attendant de du rapport et si c'est
possible on le fait si c'est n'est pas
possible on prend le temps et surtout on
ne fait pas courir de risques aux
français mais six et quinze jours
seulement avant le 28 juin ce qui est
prévu pour l'instant ça laisse très peu
de temps peut-être pour faire campagne
pour les candidats vous comprenez les
difficultés que ça soulève
non mais dans tous les cas une campagne
pour un second tour ses huit jours entre
un premier et un second tour c'est donc
le fait qu'ils aient quinze jours non le
fait est que vraisemblablement que cette
campagne là même si elle dure un peu
plus longtemps sera très contrainte en
matière de rassemblement parce que il y
à la distanciation sociale et ça on ne
peut pas mésestimer le risque avec par
exemple des rassemblements qui devront
sans doute être interdite il faudra
faire une autre forme de campagne est ce
que vous estimez que l'exécutif qui
reçoit les chefs de partis tout à
l'heure cherche à faire porter le
chapeau aux oppositions sur ce sujet ne
lui aviez pas vous justement reproché de
ne pas avoir clairement consulter des
battus au premier tour
ah non mais justement la fête justement
il nous avait consultés au premier tour
et il nous avait indiqué d'ailleurs qui
avait pas de problème on était au stade
2 l'épidémie ça avait duré 10 minutes
sur une réunion qui avait elle même duré
plus de plus de deux heures et puis
c'était le jeudi
et puis tout à coup précipitamment le
premier ministre vient la veille à 19h30
devant les caméras de télévision
dire que on passe au stade 3 d'épidémie
et que i boucle tous les lieux publics
et que le scrutin aura quand même lieu
n'avait changé rue lors d'un transfert
des charges et donc et en plus on a
essayé ensuite de mettre sur le dos
d'opposition
cette décision qui ne relevaient pas
d'ailleurs des oppositions mais bien du
président de république et du premier
ministre
donc voilà nous on a voté d'ailleurs ici
au sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale à
une très large majorité une loi cette
fois dit quoi et 10 k le rapport du
comité scientifique
il ya un conseil des ministres et que
c'est désormais au premier ministre au
gouvernement de trancher cette loi
d'ailleurs avait prévu le deuxième tour
à la fin du mois de juin si bien sûr si
les conditions sanitaires étaient réunis
bruno retailleau emmanuel macron lundi
dans un documentaire qui était diffusée
lundi soir a déclaré que le gouvernement
n'avait jamais été en rupture sur les
masques il a défendu ce qu'il a appelé
une doctrine restrictives qui était pour
lui la bonne chose à faire at il raison
pour vous non il a tort
est ce qu'il a dit est faux et j'affirme
et il n'aurait pas dû le dire il est
président de république et il devrait
avoir un rapport à la vérité plus
transparent vis-à-vis des français c'est
important parce que quand on mène un
combat on doit inspirer la confiance et
le manque de confiance des français
puisque les français sont sans doute un
des peuples de l'europe qui est le plus
sceptique vis-à-vis ses dirigeants
vis-à-vis de la façon dont ils ont
conduit la lutte contre l'épidémie et je
pense qu' il peut y avoir des fautes
il ya eu une première faute
l'impréparation l'imprévoyance pas assez
de masquer tous les français le savent
et lorsqu'il dit que personne ne parlait
des masques notamment au mois de mars
c'est faux le personnel soignant en
hôpital dans les ehpad les médecins
généralistes les chirurgiens dentistes
tout le monde en parlait capitable cas
cet exécutif rappelons le non non non
non attendez c'est ce qu'il dit vous
questionnez sur
ce qu'il a dit il a dit très exactement
comme au mois de mars au début mars
personne n'en parlait faux faux je
connais plein de médecins généralistes
qui n'étaient pas dotés en masse et les
français ont bien vu qu'il y avait cette
imprévoyance mais à cette première faute
d'un préparation il en ajoute une
seconde qui est le déni vis-à-vis de la
vérité il faut que la vérité et les
français le savent bien parce qu'ils ont
du bon sens
et bien non il ya eu un loupé un énorme
loupé de l'exécutif notamment vis-à-vis
des masques et le président de
république doit dire la vérité aux
français
il ne doit pas s'enferrer dans quelque
chose qui relève
je trouve vraiment d'une conception un
peu hasardeuse du rapport avec la vérité
c'est un mensonge
c'est un mensonge ou et cette dernière
question le conseil d'état lundi soir a
demandé au gouvernement de lever dans
les huit jours l'interdiction de
réunions dans les lieux de culte
c'était un sujet qui lui tenait à coeur
j'imagine que c'est pour vous une bonne
nouvelle qu'elle doit être la suite
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que moi
j'avais demandé que les lieux de culte
puissent être traités comme les autres
lieux publics d'ailleurs beaucoup de
lieux de culte appartiennent notamment
collectivités territoriales et je ne
voyais pas pourquoi ce serait plus
dangereux de d'entrer dans une église
une synagogue ou je ne sais où
alors que on peut rentrer dans une rame
de métro dans des heures de pointe où
les gens se pressent les uns sur les
autres donc là aussi je pense que le
gouvernement avait méconnu
une de nos libertés fondamentales qui
est la liberté de culte je reconnais
aussi que le gouvernement a un rapport
avec la liberté un peu particulier il ya
quelques jours on vient de transférer de
déférer au conseil concernait la fameuse
loi avia qui privatise la censure quand
même
au bénéfice notamment des gars femmes
voilà des sociétés multinationales
américaines
donc je trouve que là aussi c'est pas la
conception de la liberté que nous avons
ici au sénat en tout cas pour mon groupe
l'est républicain effectivement un texte
que vous avez envoyé au conseil
constitutionnel merci le mans beaucoup
bruno retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et à présent le président du
groupe uc hervé marseille il a ouvert
tout à l'heure le bal des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement c'est une
question est bien sûr ce plan de relance
1 2 du ce plan franco allemand de 500
milliards d'euros
est ce pour vous aujourd'hui une
révolution que ce plan tous les cas
c'est une nouveauté parce que comme l'a
rappelé le premier ministre
jusqu'à présent l'allemagne refusé qu'on
utilise l'europe pour faire des emprunts
c'est un sacré changement de pied à
c'est un sacré changement de pied on est
passé d'une europe qui étaient
importantes
sur laquelle on pouvait s'inquiéter
puisqu'il ne se passait rien on se
souvient de l'intervention des chinois
début de la crise
des plaintes légitimes des italiens
qui disait mais enfin que fait l'europe
et puis d'un seul coup
voyez il ya cette nouvelle qui est
excessivement importante qui est que les
français les allemands s'entendre enfin
pour débloquer la situation et faire en
sorte que l'europe puissent s'endetter
c'est un signal politique c'est pas
rattrapage par rapport à ce début de la
crise du coc vis de vous l'avez rappelé
bien il ya toutes les défaillances de
l'europe qui ont été soulignés
absolument mais c'est pas fini je veux
dire il ya déjà un beau premier point
c'est cet accord franco-allemand
maintenant il faut faire partager cet
enthousiasme au 27 17h25
et donc il va falloir convaincre les
autrichiens les hollandais ça va être
une partie facile mais enfin à partir du
moment où le moteur franco-allemand
j'avais dire se met à nouveau à tourner
avec détermination
en tous les cas c'est un signe fort
hervé marseille la semaine dernière je
vous ai interrogé sur cette question des
municipal au mois de l'original salé
municipal ans n'est ce pas oui les
municipales au mois de juin le 28 juin
bon depuis nous avons eu l'avis du
conseil scientifique elle en a été votre
lecture est ce que ça vous convainc
qu'on peut faire au mois de juin
ou pas j'ai vu que le conseil
scientifique disait qu'il était ni pour
ni contre bien au contraire il a dit au
gouvernement que c'est d'ailleurs c'est
son rôle au gouvernement il a dit au
gouvernement
c'est à vous de décider du gouvernement
visiblement se tourner d'abord vers le
parlement disant qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
visiblement la réponse en tous les cas
du sénat c'est de dire c'est fait au
mieux 1 et
aujourd'hui sont les chefs de partis qui
sont sollicités et puis à nouveau le
conseil scientifique
ma stratégie c'est une question épineuse
parce qu'on sait pas véritablement
quelle va être la situation sanitaire
fin juin personne ne veut porter le
chapeau d'une date qu'ils ne seraient
pas adéquat et relais marseille c'est
pas un problème de chapeau c'est un
problème de choix de date
c'est au gouvernement c'est sa
compétence de le faire en tous les cas
nous ici au sénat on a dit déjà depuis
plusieurs jours que si on était
interrogé nous ne nous manifestons rions
pas c'est au gouvernement de le faire on
a déjà voté
d'habitude on ne demande rien on fait
des ordonnances et cette fois ci on
voudrait qu'on vote deux fois déjà voté
le texte et on voudrait qu'on leur vote
donc nous on prendra une éventuelle
déclaration suivie d'un vote par excès
on prendre acte de la date qui sera
choisi puis c'est tout elle va très bien
merci beaucoup hervé marseille d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et à présent je
vais accueillir bernard jomier sénateur
écologiste de paris ici au groupe
socialiste vous êtes médecin de
profession bernard jomier tout d'abord
vous reprenez tout de même votre
activité parlementaire après avoir passé
six semaines à l'hôpital de melun vous
vous étiez portés volontaires quel bilan
vous tiré de cette période extrêmement
difficile pour le système de santé pour
tous les français d'ailleurs parce que
personne n'avait l'habitude d'affronter
une épidémie est donc
le gouvernement a été obligé de prendre
cette mesure très brutale du confinement
qui est un pis-aller
les hôpitaux sont retrouvés sous une
grande tension est évidemment il va
falloir maintenant qu'on tire les leçons
de tout ça et que on apprenne à vivre
avec le temps avec le virus le temps
qu'il faudra et qu'on remette notre
système de santé sur de meilleurs rails
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
ségur de l'hôpital dont olivier verrons
comment ça parlait tout à l'heure en
sortie du conseil des ministres
il a notamment dit qu'il y aurait une
hausse de salaire des soignants sans
plus de détails est-ce que vous pensez
que l'exécutif aujourd'hui va dans le
bon sens écoutée sur la hausse des
rémunérations des personnels soignants
c'est indispensable sinon ils
continueront à partir à flot de
l'hôpital comme il partait avant la
crise ils sont restés de façon très
responsable
pendant la crise mais recommenceront à
partir mais maintenant il faut dire
combien et quand est il faut cesser de
reporter la réponse
par ailleurs sur l'organisation générale
du système de santé
moi j'avais fait partie de ceux qui
avaient approuvé les principes de ma
santé 2022
le plan de la nef busin voilà mais qui a
accouché d'une loi qui était complexe et
confuse donc il ne faut pas recommencer
il ne faut pas préparé un énième
catalogue avec des experts il faut mener
de véritables états généraux de la santé
avec les personnels avec les français
avec les soignants de l'hôpital et de la
ville et pour dire clairement
qu'est ce qu'on attend de l'hôpital et à
partir de là quels moyens lui donnes ton
et qu'attend t'on des soignants de ville
du système médico social et quels moyens
leur donnes ton est ce que vous craignez
l'assouplissement des 35 heures dans
l'hôpital
l'une des mesures laquelle réfléchit
olivier ferrand cette mesure est elle
pour vous nécessaire aujourd'hui dans
l'organisation de l'hôpital
je pense que si on entre comme ça dans
le débat on va tous raté parce que
d'entrer au lieu de poser la question
des missions des objectifs repose la
question de l'organisation du temps de
travail
ça ce sont les questions qui viennent
après est par ailleurs entré par ce type
deux questions dans la réforme de
l'hôpital public c'est donner l'illusion
que j'entends bien ce discours que les
35 heures serait la cause de tous les
maux de l'hôpital public non ce n'est
pas les 35 heures qui ont empêché une
bonne réponse à l'épidémie de notre pays
il faudra être clair c'est bien autre
chose donc c'est s'égarer ou utiliser
l'épidémie pour porter ce type de
positionnement idéologique ça clairement
c'est se moquer des français olivier
véran également à planche sur des
projets de lois qui vont être transmis
aux partenaires sociaux notamment qui
prévoit un plan pour la dépendance qui
sera financée par une fraction de la csg
est ce que pour vous la création de ce
cinquième risque
eh bien c'est une bonne solution et
c'est le bon financement alors tout
d'abord moi j'ai toujours été favorable
à la création d'une cinquième branche de
la sécurité sociale
c'est un débat qui est récurrent depuis
des années moi je salue le fait que le
dossier soit réouvert maintenant il faut
là aussi procédé à une concertation et
réfléchir à la dépendance
au regard de ce qu'a été l'épidémie de
kovy cats on fait avec nos ehpad
pourquoi n'at-on pas tiré les leçons de
la canicule et de 2003 certes les
personnes âgées ne meurent plus de
chaleur dans et déshydratation dans no
et panne mais là elles sont mortes et
massivement du coc vide
donc il faut record réfléchissent
collectivement à la place des personnes
âgées dans notre société et pas de façon
infantilisante comme on l'a vu émerger
pendant cette crise avec des injonctions
qui leur sont faites où on a même on a
même envisagé de leur interdire de
sortir pendant encore et des mois et des
mois comme si elle n'était pas capable
par elle-même de décider comme les
autres adultes et bien merci beaucoup
bernard jomier d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
on va peut être avoir un dernier invité
mais tout de suite vous propose de
revoir l'un des temps forts de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
il ya eu notamment aidé à des questions
autour d'eux
de renault et des fermetures d'usinés et
plans qui ont été annoncées dans
certains médias je vous propose
d'écouter notamment la réponse de muriel
pénicaud qui répondait à une question
portant sur l'interdiction des
licenciements pendant cette période de
crise toutes les études et toutes les
expériences qu'ont été fait dans le ton
en france et dans d'autres pays ont
montré que sur le moyen terme c'est une
machine entièrement pourquoi parce que
ça fait chuter les recrutements d'une
part et que ça n'évite pas les
défaillances d'entreprises alors oui il
ya des entreprises qui étaient déjà en
difficulté avant c'est sûr que la
situation de confinement ne les a pas
aidés et va plutôt renforcé leurs
difficultés et donc il va falloir avoir
un examen à la fois sectorielle vous
l'avez dit est donc le premier ministre
et l'ensemble des ministres ont déjà
annoncé un plan sectoriel pour le
tourisme hôtellerie restauration il y
aura un bientôt dans l'automobile y aura
des plans sectoriels adapté et puis y
aura aussi un plan de relance pour
stimuler l'emploi
l'apprentissage et la formation parce
que il y aura beaucoup de mutations
intersectorielle mais je crois que du
point de vue des entreprises
il faut être rigoureux le but c'est
l'emploi mais il ne peut pas amener une
entreprise à aller vers la défaillance
qui serait encore pire puisque à ce
moment là c'est tous les emplois qui
seraient perdus coûteront seront très
attentifs au dialogue social la manière
dont s'est accompagnée et nous serons
très attentifs à la manière dont peut
aussi relancer l'activité par exemple il
ya des relocalisations stratégiques qui
peuvent être utiles dans notre pays
c'est tout ce plan d'action qui sera aux
concurrents qui viennent et s'il ya bien
un secteur qui est en train de souffrir
aujourd'hui avec cette crise du coc u19
c'est bien le tourisme je suis
d'ailleurs avec michel raison sénateurs
l ère de la haute saône vous êtes co
pilote de la cellule tourisme au sein de
la commission des affaires économiques
tout d'abord et bien bars et restaurants
devraient rouvrir le 2 juin en zone
verte si tout va bien c'est ce qu'il a
dit hier le secrétaire d'état jean
baptiste lemoyne devant le sénat ça vous
réjouit tout d'abord bonjour à vos
téléspectatrices et téléspectateurs
bonjour à vous
alors oui ça me réjouit à moitié parce
que il reste des zones rouges et vous
savez que c'est une grosse souffrance
pour les zones rouges que ce soit les
cafés et restaurants où l'hébergement
parce que les autres habitants des zones
rouges disent on va pas venir chez vous
parce que toute façon on est quand même
rouge les verts disent on va pas aller
en rouge donc c'est quand même assez
compliqué sur la partie restaurant café
restaurant évidemment que c'est déjà un
bon début
on n'a de souci déjà la zone puisque les
zones rouges si tout va normalement
devrait pouvoir ouvrir qu'à la fin du
mois
leurs souffrances sont énormes mais
surtout c'est que la réouverture avec
quatre mètres carrés par personne pose
un problème monstrueux et je pense
sincèrement qu'il faudrait réviser
c'est ça parce que ça fait c'est pas
possible quoi parce qu'avec les chars et
des risques sanitaires michel non mais
chez moi le premier moi le premier je
suis très respectueux de préserver et
d'essayer de ne pas prendre de risques
inutiles sanitaire mais on sait qu'on
pourrait faire les professionnels ont
fait quelques essais on peut faire des
on peut faire des ouvertures un peu
moins de 4 mètres carrés ça nous
permettrait d'avoir quelques clients de
plus par établissement il ya aussi la
difficulté qu'il va avoir à faire
revenir les clients et cela même si les
ouvertures la réouverture est acté alors
bien sûr les clients vont hésiter à
venir il y a beaucoup moins une personne
inconsciente compte croix puis ya aussi
ce qu'on peut être anormalement peur on
ne sait pas si c'est normal c'est
normalité des peurs et donc forcément un
certain nombre de personnes qui auraient
souhaité année ils n'iront pas il y aura
toujours assez peu de déplacements entre
département et vous avez toutes les
personnes d'un certain âge les personnes
qui ont des pathologies qui prennent
plus de précautions que les autres et
c'est bien normal et c'est souvent de
bons clients aussi donc on sait
parfaitement que la saison ne va pas se
refaire normalement vous avez fait un
certain nombre d'autres préconisations à
michel raison notamment vous demandez
aux plateformes de baisser leurs
commissions de façon temporaire
quand vous voyez qu'une plateforme
airbnb par exemple pour ne pas la nommer
licencient à tour de bras
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que cela
empire leur situation ce type de
proposition alors chacun vous savez e et
nice ainsi mais nous on aura aussi dans
les autres secteurs du tourisme parce
qu'on parle beaucoup restauration
hôtellerie on a d'autres secteurs dont
on parle pas souvent ce que j'appelle
appelé sous traitants du tourisme lavez
les grossistes en boisson vous avez les
blanchisseries vous avez tous ces gens
c'est une catastrophe
eux aussi ils vont avoir à faire des
licenciements qu'il ne souhaiterait pas
donc il faut qu'il y ait une solidarité
entre tous les maillons de la cité
plateformes ont quand même les l'errance
parce que les chansons d'abord elles
licencient mais il faut voir les
résultats qu'ils font et
et donc ils ont ils ont quand même de la
trésorerie d'avancé parce que
licenciements et résultat c'est deux
choses différentes on est bien placé
pour le savoir
un certain nombre de fois donc chacun
doit faire sa part de solidarité les
assurances par exemple c'est ce qu'on
leur demande on sait que juridiquement
ils peuvent pas tout faire ils ont
commencé d'ailleurs oui oui
effectivement la solidarité notamment
secteur de l'assurance était un secteur
sur lequel le sénat avait averti très
tôt très tôt
merci beaucoup mais je vous en dirai
plus que jamais question c'est la fin de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et de ceux de brief à 18h
vous pourrez retrouver
allant plus loin avec rebecca fitoussi
très bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]